E
NOT.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
JENNIFER GRIFFIN FROM THE
PENTAGON TONIGHT.
I KNOW MY AMERICANS ARE ASKG
TONIGH WHAT IS AMERI'S
INTEREST HERE?
A TROUBLING STORY FROMKRAINE
COME ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIS," A FATHER
AND HUSBAND DISCOVERED THAT HI
FAMILY DIED AFTER SEEING THEIR
LIFELESS BODIES AND PHOTOGRAPHS
THAT WEREUT ONLINE.
THEY REPORTEDLY KILLED B A
RUSSIAN MORT ATTACK.
OUR AYERS ARE WITH THAT FATHER
AND HIS ENTIRE FAMILY COMELL
THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE, THE
INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN THAT ARE DER FIRE
TONIGHT.
I THINK IT'SLEAR, AMERICA'S
ASKING, WHAT IS OUR ROLE HERE?
WOULD LET ME BE CLE WHAT I
THINK AMERICA'S ROLE SHOULD BE
AND NEEDS TO BE PURE NO MATTER
WHATAPPENS IN UKRAINE, WE
CANNOT HAVE AMERICAN BOOTS ON
THE GROUND.
THAT CANT BE AN OPTION.
WORLD WAR III -- WE'VE GOT TO DO
OUR VERY BEST TO TRY TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENIN PIT THAT IS
NOTOING TO END WELL.
AND FRANKLY THERE HAVE BEEN FAR
TOO MANY OCCASIONS, AND THIS IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT POINT, WHEN
POLITICIANS INASHINGTON, BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE, IN THE.S.
ARE EAGER TO SRT WARS, BUT
THEN THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOLVE
TO ACTUALLY WIN THE WARS THEY
START.
THEN AS TIME PASSESND THE WARS
COME LESS POPULAR AND TO
BECOME POLITICIZED, AND THESE
RY SAME PITICIANS THAT SENT
OUR NATIONAL TASURE, OUR MEN
AND WOMEN TO GO FIGHT THESE
WARS, THEY DECIDE NEVER MIND,
ABORT THE MISSION.
OOPS, SORRY WE MADE A MISTAKE,
T'S GET OUT AS QUICKLY A
POSSIBLE.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE PRECIOUS LOSS
OF LIFE IN THE MEANTIME?
WH HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN AND
IRAQ COULD NEVER HAPPEN AIN.
AND THA GOD WE HAVE NEW
MILITARY MODERN TECHNOLOGY THAT
CAN PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN.
DON'T FORGET, IT IS DAY-TO-DAY
207 SINCE JOE BIDEN ABANDO ENEM.
WE HAVE ANY MORAL OBLIGATION TO
DO SOMHING WHEN WE SEE MORE
CRIMINALS LIKE VLADIMIR PUTIN
BOMBING ANDVISCERATING ENTIRE
NEHBORHOODS.
YOU SAW THE REPORT JUST NOW
ABT TO LITERALLY A MATERNITY
WARD.
DOES AMERICA HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION QUESTION MIKE MANSUR
IS YES, WE DO.
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO HELP
INNOCENT HUMAN BEINGS,
ESPECIALLY WOM AND CHILDREN.
AND IN THIS CE, THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE W DEMONSTRATED THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO FIGHT FOR THEIR
COUNTRY AND PROTECT THEIRELLOW
COUNTRYMEN.
THIS IS WHERE WE CAN AND WE
SHOULD HELP THEM.
WEAN HELP THE UKRAINIANS BY
PROVIDING THE ARMS THAT THE
NEED TO PROTECT THEIR PEOPLE.
THAT IS HOW WE HELP THEM.
ARE WE CHOOSING SIDES?
YES, WE A.
WE ARE CHOOSING THE SID OF THE
SOVEREIGN.
AND I'LL BE AT, I'VE BEEN
CRITICAL OF UKRAINE'S GOVERNMT
AT TIMES.
POLITICAL CORRUPTION HAS RUN U
UNTIL ZELINSKI PRETTY RAMPANT.
BUT THIS IS A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY
THAT WAS INVADED AND AS
AMERICANS, IF WE ARE I ANY ONE
SIDE, WE ARE ON THE SIDE OF
INNOCENT CILIANS BRUTALLY
MURDEREDY VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
HIS MINIONS DOING HIS BIDDING
THAT IS WHY IT WOULD BE NICE AND
GOOD FOR THEORLD AT THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY OR HIS OWN
ADVISORS OR THE PEOPLE OF RUSSIA
STEP UP AND DO THE RIGHT THINGAY
MEANS NECESSARY.
WHEN YOU INVADE A SOVEREI
COUNTRY, THAT SHOULD BE A NEW
RULE.
YOU KILL INNOCENT MEN, WOMEN,
AND CHILDREN.
YOU FORFEIT YOUR RIGHT TO LEAD A
COUNTRY AND FRANKLY ALSO FORFEIT
YOUR RIGHT TO LIVE.
AT THE WORLD WOU BE BETTER AND
SAFER WITHOUT PUTIN AND HAD,
PERIOD.
IF WE'VE LEARNED ANYTHING FROM
LAST CTURY WHERE WELL OVER
100 MILLION PEOPLE, HUMAN SOULS
DIED BECAUSEF ISMS, COMMUNISM,
NAZI, FASCISM, THE SENIOR YOU
CUT OFF THE HEADF A MANIACAL
KILLER AND YOU CUT OFF THE HEAD
OF A SNAKE, THEN YOU START
SAVING INNOCENT LIVES.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A LOT MORE
ON PUTIN'S BLOODY INVASION OF
UKRAINE COMING OUT.
BUT FIRST, WE TURN TO AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE RIGHT HERE AT
HOME.
FOR THE THI STRAIGHT DAY,AS
PRICES ATHE PUMP JUST HIT
ANOTHER ALL-TIME RECORD HIGH.
JOE BIDEN SAYS IT IS ALL PUTIN'S
FAULT.NOTHING HE COULD DO ABOUT.
SAID THOSE VERY WORDS.
E BIDEN'S LINE.
WE DIDN'T GET HERE OVERNIGHT.
IN FACT, PRICES AT THE PUMCOME
AS YOU ALL KNOW, HAVE BEEN
RISING EVER SINCE JOE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE.
WHY HAVE THEY BEEN SING?
BECAUSE BY THEN DID EVERYTHING
HE POSSIBLY COULD WITH THE
STROKE OF PEN TO LIMIT ALL THE
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION AND
EXPLORATION RIGHT HE IN THE
S. THEM I JUST LIKE HE
PROMISED HE WOULD.
TAKE A LOOK.>> WE ARE ALL DEAD.
DOING AWAY WITH ANY SUBSTANCE OR
FOSSIL FUELS.
NUMBER TWO, HOLDINGHEM LIABLE
R WHAT THEY HAVEONE,
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE CASES
WHERE YOURE UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND DO YOU KNOW
THEEAL, OKAY?
BY THE WAY,HEN THEY DON'T --
THEY PUT THEM IN JAIL.
KIDDO, I WANT YOU TO JUST TAK A
LOOK YOU DO N'T HAVE TO AGREE.
BUT WANT YOU T LOOK AT MY
EY.
I GUARANTEE YOU, I GUARANTEE YOU
WE ARE GOING TO AND FOSSILUEL.
AND'M NOT GOING TO COOPERATE.
>> WITH THERE B ANY PCE OR
FOSSIL FUELS INCLUDING COAL AND
FRACKING IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> NO.
WE WOULDORK OUT.
WE WOULD MAKE SURE IT'S
ELIMINATED.
>> Sean: SO HE KILLED THEKEYSTOS
WENT UP.
HE BANNED DLLING IN AND WORK,
PRICES WENT UP.
HE BLOCKED NEW PERMITS ONFEDERAN
FEDERAL LANDS,ND GUESS WHAT?
PRICES WENT UP.
HE REJOINED THE PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORDS, WE ARE PAYING A
FORTUNE, AND CHINA AND INDIA
VIEWED AS DEVELOPING COUNTRIES
PAIN NEXT TO NOTHING.
HE REINSTATED CAPS ONMERICAN
PRODUCTION.
HE ADDED ENVIRMENTAL
REGULATIONS THAT ARE ALMOST
IMPOIBLE FOR ENERGY COMPANIES
TO WORK, AND PRICES WENT UP.
BIDEN'S RADICAL AGENDA LEFT
AMERICA AND OUR ALLIE FOR A
NOBLE.
BUT THERE IS SOME GOOD NEWS.
DESPITE EVERYTHING THAT HE DID
TO STYMIE OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION, HIS ADMINISTRATI
CAN STILL TAKE STEPS TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION, LOWER THE COST AT
THE PUMP, LOWER THE COST OFEVERE
WE GO TO, LOWER THE COST OF
HEATING AND COOLING OUR HOMES.
HE CAN RESTART THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE.
AND IN SPITE OF THE LIES THAT HE
AND JEN PSAKI HE BEEN SLING
AND TELLING, ACCORDING TO THE
PREMIER OFLBERTA, CANADA, THIS
PIPELINE COULD BE TURD AROUND
IN LESS THAN ONE YEAR.
ONCE COMPLETED IT WOULD INCREASE
CRUDE OIL CAPACITY IN THE
UNITED STATES BY ALMOST
90000 BARRELS A DAY, WHICH
WOULD MAKE UP AND THEN SOME ALL
OF THE OIL THAT JOE HAS BEEN
IMPORTED FROM RUSSI
AND HE WOULDN'T HAVE TO BEG
VEZUELA AND IRAN FOR THIS IS
ONLY -- MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT IN EUROPE, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTTION IS OPPOSING THE
EASTERN MEDITERRAAN PIPELINE
WHICH WOULD SUPPLY WESTE
EUROPE WITH NATURAL GAS FROM
ISRAEL.
JOE NEEDS TO IMMEDIATELY SUPPORT
THIS.
HE DOESN'T ANYMORE.
HE IS CONTROLD BY THE CLIMATE
ALARMIST CULT.
IF THE ADMINISTRATION WAS AREVES
THE GREEN LIGHT TO ALL OF THESE
PROJECTS, MUCH-NEED NATURAL
GAS WOULD BEGIN TO FLOW INTO
EUROPE.
IT IS DESPERATELY NEEDEAND WE
CAN WEAN OUR ALLIE OFF OF
RUSSIAN OIL AND ENERGY HIM TO
STOP MAKG PRUDENT AND RICH
AGAIN WOULD BANKRUPT RUSSIA AND
PUTIN'S REIGN OF TERROR BECAU
RUSSIA WOULD BE POOR AGAIN.
AT THIS NEW SUPPLY WOULD
OBVIOUSLY  A FACTOR IN THE
GLOBAL ENERGY MARKET AND O
COURSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
COD ALSO REINSTATE DRILLING
AND LIFT THE BAN ON NEW DOMESTIC
AND OFFSHOREXPLORATION HERE.
ALL OF THIS WOULD LOWER COST.
IT WOULD INCREASE SPLY.
AND EQUAL THE PRICE.
INCREASE THE SUPPLY, DEMAND
REMAINS CONSTANT, PRICE GOES
DOWN.
IT WLD ALSO CREATE HIGH PAYING
AMERICAN JOBS AND WE WLDN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT RUSSIA, WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO WOR ABOUTHE
STREETS OFUR MOODS, OR ANY
ENERGY ISSS INVOLVED IN THEMIDD.
OTHER WORDS, ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
ANYWAY, THAT WOULD REQUIRE
LITTLE COUGE FROM JOEY.
HE WOU NEED TO STAND UP TO HIS
NEW GREEDEAL CLIMATE ALARMIST.
WHY YOU WOULD EVER NEGOTIATE
WITH THE MOANS OF IN THAT HAVE
THATENED TO WIPE ISRAEL IN THE
U. OFF THE MAP, DEATH TO
AMICA, DEATH TO ISRAEL.
IR, THE NBER ONE STATE
SPONSOR OF TERRORISM WORLDWIDE.
THIS IS WHERE IT GETS REALLY
CRAZY
RUIA RIGHT NOW, VNNA, IS
BROKERING THE NEW NUCLEAR DEA
THAT JOEY WANTS WITH IRAN.
AND THE UNITED STATES.
IRAN WON'T TK TO US DIRECTLY.
SO RUSSIA ISN THE MIDDLE
NEGOTIATING.
I'M SURE THEYRE DOING A GREAT
JOB FOR IN.
ACCORDING TO JUST THE
NEWS.COM -- THAT IS JOHN
SOLOMON SIDE, TOP RUIAN
NEGOTIATOR BRAGGED, IN GOT
MUCHORE THAN THEY EVER
EXPECTED.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT SOME
$90 BILLION IN ON FROZEN CASH
AND OTHER ASSET
OIL EXPORT GUARANTEES.
VERY LITTLE ERSIGHT
SURROUNDING THE URANIUMENRICHMET
STANUP TO THE CLIMATE ARMIST
AT HIS OWN PARTY.
SO WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE?
JOE BIDEN IS LITERALLY PUTTING
HIS PARTY'S RADIC AGENDA OVER
YOUR WALLETS.
HE'S WILLING TO GIVE YOU A 40
YEAR HIGH WI INFLATION.
HE IS PUTTING HIS RADICAL AGENDA
OVER THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF
TH AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FRANKLY
THE SAFY AND SECURITY OF
PEOPLE AUND THE WORLDHE IS GOINR
ONE STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR RICH
AGAIN AND NONE OF THAT MAKES THE
WORLD A SAFER PLACE.
NDING MONEY TO A SOCIALI
DICTATOR?
SENDING AN EMISSARY OVER THE
WEEKEND?
THAT DOES NOT MAKE THE WORLD A
SAFEPLACE.
GIVING OPEC ALL THE LEVERAGE
THEY WANTVER THE U.S., THAT
ESN'T MAKE THE WORLD A SAFER
PLACE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, RESTRICTING OIL
AND GAS PRUCTION HERE IN THE
U.S. -- TT WILL CONTINUE TO
SPUR MASSIVE INFLATION.
OBVIOUSLY JOE DOESN'T CARE.
HE WOULD RATHER DEAL WITH THE
DICTATS.
EVERYTNG YOU BUY IS PRODUCED
AND SHIPPED
THEY USE OIL, GAS, DIESEL TO GET
IT THERE
THAT IS WHY MONTH OVER MONTH
INFLATION CONNUES TO RISE
UNLESS OF COURSE Y ARE LIVING
IN THIS ULTIMATE UNIVERSE LIKE,
CIRCLE BACK PROPAGANDA
JEN PSAKI.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STEPS
IS TO COMPUTE IF YOU COMPARE
MONTHO MONTH, WE'VE SEEN
INFLATNARY NUMBERS GO DOWN
MONTH-TO-MONTH, EVEN AS WE
LOOKED AT THE YEAR-TO-YEAR
NUMBERS GO UP, WHICH WE ENTIRELY
EDICTED.
>> THAT IS AOLUTELY NOT TRUE.
JUST TO KNOW THAT JEN PSAKI IT
JOE BIDEN LIED.
WE ARE AT A 40 YEAR HIGH FOR
INFLATION AND THAT IS MONTH
AFTER MONTH.
BUT IT WASN'T HER ONLY LIE OF
THE DAY.
SHE STILL WANTS YOU TO BELVE
THAT GAS PRICES ARE ONLY GOINGUT
AND GREEDY OIL COMPANIES THAT
ARE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
LEASES THAT TY HAVE GENEROUSLY
GIVEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Sean: WHY DID YOU GUYS
DECIDE TO REBRAND THEISINGAS
PRICES AS THE --
>> IF YOU WANT T USE THAT ON
FOX, I WELCOMEHAT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN -- THEY
BELIEVE THATHEY HAVE OIL OR
GLASS IN THEM?
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THAT
ACCUSATION IS A COMPLETE RED
HERRIN
TO SOME PERMITS ARE VIABLE AND
SOME ARE NOT.
YOU SAYHAT, THIS REPRESENTS A
NDAMENTAL MISUNDERSTANDIN
INTO HOW TS PROCESS WORKS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, NEARLY 60%
REMAIN NONPRODUCIN
THAT IS A LOT IN THE RANGE OF
20 MILLION ACRES.
SO THERE ARE 9,000NUSED
APPROVED PERMITS TO DRILL THEM.
THEY SHOULD NOT -- THAT SHOULD
NOT REQUIRE US INVITING THEM TO
DO THAT.
THEY SHOULD DO THAT TMSELVES.
TO SPEAK OF THE ADDITIONAL
PERMITS
>> WHAT DID THE
THEY -- THE LEASES ARE THERE,
THPERMITS ARE TRE, I DON'T
THINK THEY NEED AN EMBROIDERED
INVITATION.
>>ean: I GUESS SHE GOT HOM
THAT GETS HER FROM FAKE NEWS
CNN.
INASE YOU'RE WATCHING TONIGHT,
JEN,ERE'S AN IMPORTANT FACTOR
YOU NEED TO KNOW AND YOU
PROBABLY DO.
DESPITE YOUR CLAIM, OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES ARE NOT JT SITTING
ON 9,000 UNUSED APPROVED OIL
DRILLING PERMITS.
THESE LEASES ARE ISSUED PRIOR TO
EXPLORATION.
SO NOT ALL OF THOSE LEASE
ACTUALLY HAVE OIL AND GAS IN THE
GRND THAT CAN BE EXTRACTED.
AND OTHER WORDS, ENERGY
COMPANIES ARE NOGOING TO DRILLFT
DS UP NOT HAVING OIL, EVEN IF
THEY HAVE THE PERMIT TO